I still am like I can't stand watching
myself I have a weird thing I hear that
a lot with actors like it's very hard
for me because I myself I'm my biggest
critical look are you looking at your
face no never mind I'm just looking at
like acting my acting all right so you
you're okay looking at yourself yeah
like you're like I'm pretty I'm not
worried about that is that what you're
saying I mean I
don't know but it's a good thing it's
good to know that's a I'm telling you
ninety percent of actors don't like
watching themselves because they're like
oh God my nose oh look at the bags under
my eyes look at this what's very
interesting is in acting even if I like
I feel like I've talked to a lot of
people that are very aware of how
they're they look when they're like
crying or if they're screaming when I'm
acting I could care if I look
ugly I'm like great good I was in it
that was it I could care less if there's
like tears and I'm like no snot coming
down trust the director yes I'm like
this is acting this is what it is like
you're not in real life like worried
about like snot coming down your nose
and being like
have you had those moments where you're
crying like that yeah most recently I
was working on a film called horoscope
with Sony pictures I just got back from
it
um so I was there for three months in
Belgrade Serbia who's in that um Jacob
battle on from Spider-Man
um Harriet Slater
who else
umbrella Gonzalez yeah there's seven
it's an ensemble cast there's seven of
us all leads and scary scary movie Yes
deals with horoscopes and a lot of what
you know this generation is very into
horoscopes these days and I think it
will do there's also like a sense of
entertainment to it
um
I think it will do really well and I'm
very excited about it it comes out in
2023 in theaters so great you'll have to
email me and let me know so Ryan and I
can go see it yeah let's go right I'll
go but wait a minute you were about to
tell me something that happened on that
side oh yeah yeah so
it's V I think this is why I love horror
the most I think it's the most wait a
minute you like horror the most I think
I walk around you well look at us look
around you
look up here
it's a little rubber band yeah Elizabeth
probably knows it I never know yeah none
of us we didn't catch on so late yeah
sorry no I think I love it because it's
the most I think the most challenging
genre
um especially for me that's just how I
feel but putting yourself in these like
most the most unrealistic like
circumstances and truly believing it and
like I had a scene I had to do I can't
like share the scene but like something
that was so just like horrible yeah
something that's just so it's not gonna
happen so unrealistic but like truly
believing it and that was where it's
like you have like five cameramen that
are just like there and Soundstream too
or whatever no we weren't on a green
screen she's a real creature or whatever
don't say anything stop yeah
um but to like be looking at people like
you know cough like doing a little thing
like that or just adjusting and moving
and that's you're looking and trying to
believe what you're seeing it's well not
only that
but you're at the beginning of your
career so everything's new so yeah you
being on set with all the crew and all
the cast and the producers and the
director and they're all watching you
and they're like
um
um Larson are you I forgot your name for
a second
no no I'm kidding because I was going to
say Laura Lars because I was thinking
son because that was your grandma's yes
spelling of her yeah no and they were
like okay Larson
and you gotta start crying and be
emotional totally and the most important
thing you have to do which you probably
don't have a lot of experience doing is
really trusting yourself yeah which that
never
I've done stuff where I just I'm like I
don't I don't I don't know and some the
first take they're like okay then he's
it needs to be a little big we need to
see more emotion second take okay and by
the fifth take I get there yeah because
there's no way you're gonna get there in
the first take with those emotions
totally totally I mean she's crying
she's crying keep rolling guys keep
rolling fix the snot on her nose and
then I want to get that because that's
ridiculous okay good let's distract well
I take a second too where I'll just be
like hey I'm gonna need like you call
Action give me a few seconds I'm gonna
like scream and get there like
emotionally you have your things to do
yeah I do my things well I do I will
I'll sit there and I go come on God
and I'll yell at myself and I go come on
dude let's go you know just something
I've seen like I worked with Jesse
Eisenberg and uh the other Lex Luthor I
love him he was great to work with um
and what he does before every take he
just jumps up and down
and turns in circles turns in circles
turns in circles wow yeah and I you know
if you have to be kind of like if I'm
playing a drugged up or emotional
sometimes I'll spin around I'll do
something whatever it takes to get me
going exactly and it's like
it's where it's like
so I'll go like
I'm like they're like we need you I'm
like all right I'm up I'm I'm here I'm
ready